[Music]
hey guys Dimitri from the score esports
now 2019 was a big year for bolo
he went from dumpster indictments on
youtube to winning Dreamhack bolo and
Merck to step it up for their team I
mean they deserve it you look at every
land event they've attempted as they
lift the trophy everybody welcome your
2019 Dreamhack Montreal champions for
years the siege community wondered
whether this crazily talented youtuber
would have what it takes to cut it in
the big leagues and needless to say 2019
s given us a pretty definitive answer so
we figured what better time to count
down the top ten times that bolo went
nutty as hell now in an effort to be
authentic we've included clips from
ranked play since those are the ones
that made him so famous to begin with
that said we've only included ones where
he went up against future former or
current pros but before we get on with
our list
we just wanted to remind you all that
there is plenty of US Nationals action
yet to come in order to keep up with it
all be sure to check out the links in
the description below now that's enough
filled up it's time to get on with our
list kicking off our list is the lovely
little 2k that bolo picked up in his
very first pro league match watch as the
one and only boy Lowe makes his
thunderous debut against Space Station
gaming in their season 10 matchup
against Team solomid I got hill on the
fosco and then I got a plane I think I
got a claim with killing chopper
around 4 because my first clutch
situation it was all down on me and I
wanted able to do his best but now Bosco
will walk away from that one in great
success now keeping around bathroom as a
chief takes out thinking a polo next in
line chala takes that achieved there's
bolo to drop Bosco and everybody's
trading back and forth but it's a claim
on a bolo as chala tries to break on out
and it's a big round from TSM's newest
member and that'll be four in a row for
TSM throw conventional
to note the window here Michael because
Villa is going in favor of the attackers
[Music]
coming in at number nine is this all too
famous 1v5 overtime clutch on bandit
from the wall bangs to the flicks to the
fake outs this is the ideal Volo ace
[Music]
and then usually tweet saying you may
not like it but this is what peak
performance looks like see what I did
there it's like the the full bolo
experience the flicks the wall bang
someone in tact going you know going
crazy all the hedge dots and just those
little good time back then this super
clutch 4k comes in at number eight the
boy racked it up against team
reciprocity on Doc in the Rolly major
qualifiers just wait until you see that
Guddi asks Tim there's a good job there
from below as Merck gets wait up a bolo
gets a kill they're on to us guys so not
looking good here for Team reciprocity
is they have to make this work with only
40 seconds left might gonna catch him
bolting retro does catch Bert quilting
over as he does nice hit a nice pick he
might get to know he does not get to
Bullock 125 HP but he's doc and we heal
himself he gets out of your laxing in
the Box they pick up two and then fire
watch it gets one on two box a market
one on a biologic porn now it's a 1 p1
all over his flax molasses in the site
urn LX not on the site bolos on the site
but he doesn't have them users relaxing
here they don't want people in follow he
hears them juicing up to his left
can you get the shots no he doesn't bolo
Fukuoka long
they're a nice plush viola right there
in the 1b1
I think you did try to push a little bit
- sure paid the price for that man
coming in at number seven is none other
than the 11 second lion ace that bulu
pulled off several weeks after lion was
introduced to siege lion was just like
them or thick operator as you know he
wasn't too slow
he had a fifty round mag and you know he
had the scanner and if there was a line
with a 1 X running into the building
while scanning you're basically done for
if this isn't proof of how toxic the
operator was prior to his rework I don't
know what is
[Applause]
oh my god dude what this 20 seconds was
it like for a cigar
what the stop an absolutely filthy
3-piece that bolo picked up against
disrupt gaming in stage two of the 2019
US Nationals clocks in at number 6 on
our list honestly this looks like it
could have been taken from a pub game
come on beau why you got to him like
that a bug bringing out the game along
with post this and make huge entail for
disrupt nice trade coming through in
bolo is it go ahead and take right now
captain 3k all headshots
I love Marcy and I know none of us
suspected that football of an absolute
even somewhere on the map I knew I knew
they missed it on streem said I was like
damn that's that really sucks cuz it was
I was I was kind of proud of it I think
Billy was like like telling Mars he
didn't like look at my cam but by the
time you by the time he said that it was
too late there's all I was all done the
damage has been done
coming into the halfway point is bolos
absolutely ballistic garage take against
teamliquid in the grand finals of
dreamhack Montreal 2019 - yes em they
really gotta get a move on 20 seconds
left waiting for any potential blanks
coming from liquid and still can't deal
with these echo drones cannot spot them
cannot dispatch olympos are going to the
plant now another smoke vilandra Dhanam
and jarvis attempted flank shut down in
the back by hollow and pose always been
down now picking up the diffuser and
planting will be following to hold this
turn a rush back through pojos finished
off with a nitro bowlers looking to the
plant down hill complete it to be three
into the post plant here and they'll
bail out the garage now waiting for any
flanks come from up a fog would lighting
up although the diffusers coming out
from sexy cake but it stopped that it's
trashed by bolo down to the 2v2 and she
can pull out the control but paul with a
beautiful shot down to the 1v1 it's
bhalo against paul who on top that if
these are now peeking up the garage
polish has to kill a little bit of time
we can try and spot him underneath the
car for some foot shots and now walking
outside completely detected part of
dancing around the car in a bowl with
clutch it up six one kiss him it was
just everybody like on top of their game
like hojo going in at the right time to
plant and he got he got downed I I took
the diffuser from him I am you Lee
started planting Merc was right on my
right on me just to get my trade and
cover me and sacrificed his life so the
bomb could get down and then we just
played post playing up to that next is
one of the juiciest bolo clips out there
that's right we're talking about the
time bolo ace to stack in which four
members of evil geniuses were present
and it's taking number four on our list
[Music]
it
[Music]
well I evolved one HP and I'm gonna
request the systems ASAP
no honey at 1 more times now there we go
and it's even better when you watch it
from Canadians perspective
[Music]
in that game on skyscraper I was just
like I was on a heater but a seen frozen
drink that wasn't my first time back
then so it's kind of it's always nice
whenever like you're playing against you
know other people that are known in the
communities so you always kind of get
like you know props in your chat but
also it kind of sucks for the other
person because then they get you know
they get some hate in their chat coming
in at number three is bolos first ever
pro league ace against reciprocity in
the Rallye major qualifiers he wants to
win the first one for his team at the
plant is going down Merck does the bolo
to cover maybe home he's off I'm home at
first I wasn't like like right after I
wasn't like oh my get bail is like my
first early game I was just like wow I
dumpster those guys like so this is kind
of like a lot of adrenaline going on I
still want to know continue out the game
but afterwards like when I realized I'm
like yeah nice first ace in the bag and
so felt felt it felt good
now this is perhaps the be-all and
end-all of blow plays the spawn peaking
1v5 and it takes the penultimate spot on
our list it would have been impressive
against anyone but as fate would have it
bolo happened to be playing against
four-fifths of Brazil's famous black
dragons roster that's right
you're watching bolo clutch a 1v5 from
his spawn against a pro league staff
I spawned in and literally like within
seconds my whole team is just dead like
they all got swampy like I I knew it
before I am like I'm kind of like
playing it like cool like in the spawn
because I know no LATAM they're pretty
pretty known 3 and other aggressive
they're keeping all of that so I was
like okay I think I even said like
before like it's not in the video but I
think I said like watch after spawn
Peaks or something like that so I was
cooling it they all died I was like well
they're probably gonna peak you for the
kill
so I'll just I'll just play my hand at
to see if I can get some pics and I got
I got I think what three yeah three
outside on ruins and then when I you
know doing all the numbers and I just
slowly pushed in and that's when I just
took the 1b ones they they gave me the
one b12 I was I'm looking for them yeah
hang a right around this clip like
release like when I kind of like started
you know like getting up there and like
view that's when people are sort of like
you know doing the whole like they could
bolo flick bolo lean like like tying
everything like that like I kind of it
kind of got me on the map I wasn't on
the map a little bit before that but
then was like it was I became more known
for like the the mechanical movement and
everything I'm pretty sure like when
this happened like that whole like that
like it was like a sigh or something I
was pretty sick when this happened I
think after that game I Divac a just
went to bed for like eight hours or
something like that just to try to
recover from my like I think I might I
think I might have had the flu at the
time
taking the top spot on our list is the
moment bolo finally managed to turn pro
league into a ranked match the moments
at which in a grand final on one of the
biggest stages and siege bolo finally
gave his fear all following and the
North American siege audience at large
exactly what they've been waiting for
TSM attacking the sunrise they know that
these guys are gonna be extended into
kitchen
I think TSM might overextend for office
and out of your bones just in the site
what is going on how is he even able to
enter now he's got control
hopefully the bomb is caught the bomb is
being planted out of nowhere
TSM making an aggressive brush in a rush
plant this next pinkie will take down to
there but it's right over from bolo now
we stand on a 3v3 in the post plant
cenario another one boats heading down
but Paulie would get one bolo with three
on the round now looking for more it's
down to the to be too sexy k QPSK
collapsing from the blue bar in a
kitchen area trying to bring in some
yokai drones drones in the attack beside
being sent out as well although not
spotting the yokai coming closer and
closer to jaws is the Camco pies but now
in the hallway that's four for bolo
we'll look at the ACE turning the corner
given the ACE put it in the montage TSM
o2o
the confidence coming from bolo right
there I mean she is just unstoppable
right now the thing is I didn't know it
was an ace until like after the game I
didn't I didn't even know like I was
just I was just so caught up in the
moment
I was just so hyped and just the all the
adrenaline and everything like that it
was it was it was so real definitely
crazy cuz again I was like I've been a
spectator this you know the eSports
scene for a long long time and I even
went to New Jersey Atlantic City for the
season seven finals where liquid one and
then being able to you know play against
them for a spot at the Invitational
you know acing them and just do it like
just giving my my 100 like a hundred
percent to the game and just winning is
its and that was emotional that was that
was crazy that was really really
something like I fight these days for
myself
well guys you've heard it from the man
himself those are the top 10 best bolo
plays
be sure to hop in the comments and let
us know if there's any sick place that
you think we missed make sure to like
the video subscribe to the channel and
we'll see you next time thanks for
watching if you want more content like
this hit the sub button and ring that
notification bell for unique bite-sized
videos you will find anywhere else hit
up our Instagram Twitter and Facebook
pages
[Music]